la guerre est inévitable il faut parfois
détruire afin de créer
nous ne sommes pas des Jedi
[Musique]
j'entends depuis peu des rumeurs
concernant le retour de Spawn en tant
qu'héritier de l'Empire
que se passera-t-il quand nous trouvons
ce Rhône
plus que tu n'en n'as jamais rêvé
[Musique]
j'ai passé presque toute ma vie à faire
la guerre
et c'est pour ça que je vous demande de
m'aider à en éviter une autre
tu sais comme moi qui pourrais surmonter
des
[Musique]
mais elle est aussi têtue que je l'ai
toujours connu
je parie que t'en mettre te trouver
difficile quelquefois Anakin n'a jamais
fini ma formation de Jedi je lui ai
tourné le dos tout comme j'ai tourné le
dos à Sabine toi tu n'as jamais fait ce
genre d'effort pour moi
[Musique]
maître
en tant que Jedi tu es parfois obligé de
prendre des décisions impossibles
mais je compte sur toi pour aller
jusqu'au bout
ça te va bien
on est parfois obligé de faire notre
devoir sans tenir compte de ce qu'on
peut ressentir
si nous n'arrêtons pas ce Rhône tout ce
qu'on a fait aura été en vain
tu n'as pas le moindre pouvoir Anakin
je ne suis pas venu ici pour discuter de
mon passé
nous avons de nombreuses
[Musique]